c'est l'éducation canine parce que
justement en prévision du bébé pour moi
c'était hyper important que le chien
soit soit à l'aise avec le bébé donc
j'ai beaucoup investi au départ c'était
à raison de 90 dollars par semaine
l'éducateur qui en est venu à la maison
et ont préparé beaucoup l'arrivée du
bébé donc et on faisait beaucoup de
manipulations justement ce dont les
jeunes enfants sur les oreilles sur la
culture le poids donc on est habitué à
ce genre de manipulation là pour qu'il
soit désensibiliser si on veut donc je
me croise les doigts m'adapte très
branché avec les enfants
mon dieu je dois être au tour là je vais
être dans les 1000 1500 $ maintenant
depuis un an que je dépense mais comme
je dis pour moi c'était ça venez avec
l'investissement avant éventuellement
ils ne dépensent que je peux vraiment
pas assumer ben va falloir prendre une
décision là savoir si on regarde de chez
nous non ça reste un animal pour moi
c'est plus sympa graduée au niveau de
l'être humain
donc c'est ma dépense s'arrête là